احلام الثراء السريع نقطه الضعف التي
يستغلها عصابات الاحتيال في مصر القصه
متكرره لكن نصاب هذه المره او المشتري كما
يطلق عليه في مصر هو الانترنت
هوك بول هو تطبيق الكتروني انطلق في اغسطس
الماضي بغرض الاستثمار وتعدين العملات
المشفره اوهم الضحاياها بالربح الفوري عن
طريق الهاتف او الكمبيوتر واغرضتهم بضخ
مزيد من الاموال من اجل ربح اكبر واسرع
الى المنصه نجحت في الاستيلاء على سته
مليارات جنيه قبل اغلاق الموقع والاختفاء
لكن في بيان جديد نشرته وزاره الداخليه
المصريه عبر الانترنت جاء فيها ان المبلغ
الاجمالي يقدر بتسعه عشر مليون جنيه وان
الاجهزه الامنيه تمكنت من ضبط التشكيل
العصابه وعددهم 29 شخصا
حاجه تدفع 4000 جنيه كمان خمس ايام هيجي
لك 20,000 في بقى حاجه اكبر ادفع 8000
وبعد خمس ايام هينزل لك 40,000 يعني روح
ادفع 12
هينزل لك 60,000 انا طمعت
وعملت في نفسي نصيبه رحت
الف بعت تليفون اخويا الصغير لسه جايبه
جديد
ودخلت ناس معايا بالفلوس التانيه وقلت لهم
الفلوس
ما بينهم وما بينكم ومضيت على نفسي
الكلام ده كله يوم 25 يعني انا ما كملتش 3
ايام 3 ايام حطيت الفلوس حطيت الفلوس اللي
كنت حاطاها قبل كده مفاجاه تلات ايام بس
والبرنامج قفل والفلوس راحت وانا انا مش
عارفه
من القاهره ينضم الينا محامي ضحايا تطبيق
فول عبد العزيز حسين سيد عبد العزيز اهلا
بك معنا في صباح العربيه شكرا على تواجدك
معانا لتشرح لنا هذه القضيه شركه وهميه
للاستثمار والارباح تنصب على عشرات
المصريين ما الذي حصل تحديده
صباح الخير يا فندم على حضرتك وصباح الخير
على كل مشاهدينك الكرام اهلا وسهلا
بسيادتك في البدايه بدا الموقع حضرتك من
14/8/2022
في الحقيقه
اتنصب على كثير من الناس زي ما حضرتك في
التقرير كده اللي هو بتدخل حاجه اسمها اله
مثلا ب 1600 في خلال 100 يوم تاخد على
اليوم الواحد اربعه دولار خير كمان سيادتك
ان المشرفين كل اما حضرتك كل اما تدخلي حد
مع حضرتك او تجيبي حد زي زي ما حضرتك في
التقرير اللي تم بتاخدي على الشخص الواحد
اتنين دولار وكل اما الشريحه تعلى او
الاله تعلى تاخذي على الفرد الواحد اربعه
دولار طبعا زي ما حضرتك عارفه وشفتوا
البيان امبارح وبيان بيان النيابه العامه
وبيان الداخليه تم القبض على حوالي 19 شخص
منهم 13 جنسيه اجنبيه تمام في الحقيقه
طبعا ان ان احنا لما قدمنا بعدد من
المحاضر في مديريات الامن على مستوى
الجمهوريه باعتبار احد المحامين الممثلين
عن الضحايا والله يا فندم احنا ورد الينا
ناس كتير في ناس امبارح اول امبارح ماتت
ماتت ماتت فعلا من الصدمه ناس حتى تشائع
عمرها ناس بعت اراضي لها ناس مضت على
نفسها ايصالات امانه ناس باعت عربياتها
ناس بعد بيوتها طبعا ده كله علشان
الثراء السريع كل واحد فينا النهارده
بيحلم بالسراء السريع
بدايه طبعا كانت
اليوم عم بيقولوا لك انه هذا التطبيق او
هاي المنصه اللي ظهرت اغسطس الماضي مرخصه
يعني رخصه سجل تجاري مصري كيف مرخصه
تمام تمام يا فندم بص حضرتك عندنا هنا
يعني في في الاستثمار احنا بنسهل كل
الاجراءات التراخيص لجميع
اي حد حابب يستثمر يعني انا حضرتك وانا
الشركه انا مش محتاج من حضرتك غير غير
بطاقه سريعه وغير عادي ايجار وغير توكيل
وحضرتك هسلمك الشركه في خلال اربعه ايام
ليه احنا هنا للاسف ان احنا بنستخدم
التسهيلات للمستثمرين بطريقه خاطئه
فبالتالي حضرتك فعلا انا قدمت من ضمن
المحاضر ان قدمت السجل التجاري وطبعا
الناس عارفه ان ده يعني في بعض الاراء انه
يقول لك ده بيتكوين او الكلام ده الناس ما
تعرفش اساسا يعني ايه كلمه بيتكوين اصلا
ولكن ان هم اللي يعرفوه ان هم ده تجاره في
في تكنولوجيا المعلومات صناعه التكنولوجيا
المعلومات والبرمجه واجهزه الحاسب الالي
بناء على طبعا مع حضرتك ما ورد في السجل
التجاري ونشاطه تمام في ثاني حاجه كمان يا
فندم ده هم مسكت وش عن كده وبعد ما قفلوا
المواقع على فكره اللي تم رصده حوالي 19
مليون ولكن هم اكثر من كده بكتير انا بس
19 مليون دول من بعض الضحايا اللي عندي
فيهم حتى نفهم احنا حفايا ما حصل طيب وصل
عدد المشتركين في هذه المنصه الوهميه 600
الف كانت الارباح يوميه طبيعيه وحتى
تتضاعف وصلت
ما الذي حصل بعدها
تمام تمام يا فندم اللي اشترك على على
البرنامج او على الابليكيشن حوالي 800 الف
واحد تمام تم النصب عليهم هم اللي ورد او
ذكر ان هم حوالي 500 الف ولكن هم 800 الف
على حسب السيستم اللي احنا شفناه تمام
طبعا بعد ما الناس كل في حاجه اسمها الات
لو مثلا حضرتك دفعت في قلب 1600 بتاخدي
اربعه دولار لمده 100 يوم تمام فبالتالي
بيبقى مثلا معاكي 30 40,000 جنيه 50,000
كلما حضرتك تعلب الاله كل ما تزيد معك
فجاه تلات اربع ايام حضرتك اهمل الابلكيشن
قفل خالص ووقف فجاه كل حاجه اتبخرت الفلوس
طبعا في ناس عندي موكلين في ناس بمليون
ومائتين في ناس بمليون في ناس ب700000 كل
واحد يا فندم كل واحد حاول بقدر الامكان
ان هو يجيب فلوس ويستلف فلوس وفي ناس اخذت
كروت علشان حضرتك ان هم يوظفوها مع الناس
دي باعتبار البرمجه باعتبار اجهزه الحاسب
الالي عبد العزيز هل قدرتوا توصلوا لهم
وشو العقوبه القانونيه وهل يمكن ارجع حقوق
لتم النصب عليهم
سؤال محترم يا فندم طبعا تم الوصول للبعض
حوالي 19 واحد كانوا في 2 فيلا موجودين
بيمارسوا نشاطهم الاجرامي اتمسك اكتر من
995 محفظه الكترونيه واكثر من 41 كارت ده
بنكي وحوالي 3000 3000 موبايل
الداخليه في الحقيقه لما احنا بدانا
وقلنا ان في ضحايا كتير تم تشكيل فريق عمل
طبعا احنا بنشكر وزير الداخليه وكل
الادارات سواء اداره تكنولوجيا المعلومات
او مباحث الاموال العامه او مباحث
الاتصالات على الجهد المبذول ده انا ما
كنتش متوقع ان هم احنا وصل لهم بالسرعه دي
ولكن الحمد لله عندنا اجهزه قويه
طبعا يعني خالص الشكر والتقدير لهم في ناس
كثير بقى بتسال هو احنا ممكن ترجع لنا
فلوسنا احنا بقدر الامكان احنا فيه دلوقتي
متهمين بالنسبه لنا وبنحاول بقدر الامكان
ان شاء الله ان احنا نوجههم كل التهم تمام
واحنا ان شاء الله في في القضاء باذن الله
او في الاجراءات القانونيه بعد كده هنطالب
بتعويضات ليهم على حسب طبعا احنا منتظرين
حسب القيد الوصف يا فندم بتاع النيابه حسب
ما توصف النيابه احنا بعد كده احنا
كمحامين هنشتغل عليها احنا بنشكرك جزيل
الشكر اكيد للحديث تتمه من القاهره محامي
ضحايا تطبيق
عبد العزيز حسين شكرا جزيلا لك
وقبل ما نذهب لابراهيم تعرضته للاحتيال
يوما ما والنصب لان الحمد لله ابراهيم
الانترنت لا ههه
قصه حقيقيه انه صارت معي يوما ما في حياتي
انه قالوا لي انه انا ربحت نصف مليون
ولازم بس ابعت عشر الاف درهم ابعتيهم بس
كنت كتير صغيره كتير فما يعني شفتي الطماع
مع هذا الثراء السريع
انه تطبع ادخل المدخل انه يكون انسان طماع
دائما معظم الضحايا في هيك عملياتهم
متطمعين لانه ربح سريع فبالتالي
لازم تفترض سوء النيه فيك امور قبل
الايميل لما يجيك لازم تشوفوا وتعد للعشره